-Oh!
-Was this a baby shower?
-It's a baby shower.
-So Serena Williams.
-Yes.
-You were at her baby shower.
-Yeah.
-You're good friends
with Serena, and it was --
it looks like, what is it,
'50s sock hop theme?
-'50S. It's a '50s theme.
Serena's really big on
theme parties, which is, like,
such a pain in the ass.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so happy
to hear you say that.
-[ Sighs ]
-Because friends who are
into theme parties,
it's such a burden.
-Oh, my gosh!
It's such a burden.
I gotta go find an outfit.
I have to make sure it fits.
Like, actually,
if you look closely at
my dress,
I went to a Halloween shop
in Miami Beach
'cause this was in Florida.
And there's pirates on my dress,
'cause it's actually
a pirate outfit,
'cause I couldn't find
a '50s outfit.
-Oh, my goodness.
-But I sewed it to make it look
like a '50s outfit.
-That's very impressive.
Now is she the kind of person
who has a theme party and if you
had shown up in sort of --
-Oh, you get like, shade.
-Oh, really?
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
You get the looks of like,
"oh, you didn't dress up."
-Too good for the '50s.
-Too good to dress up, huh?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so you have to.
-You mention that you sewed it.
You actually know how to sew.
-Yeah.
Which -- I want to talk about
your fashion line.
-Yeah.
-but I feel like a lot of people
have fashion lines,
and I feel like there are many
who have never sewn.
-Right.
-But you are --
-No, I sew.
I mean, I don't sew each piece
in my fashion line. [ Laughs ]
-[ Laughs ] Right. Yeah.
-But I've been sewing
since I was, like, 7.
I used to sew, like, curtains
and pillows and then I --
-When you sewed curtains,
were they for your room
or for other people? Okay.
-Yeah. Both, both.
I actually started because,
I had an aunt who always said,
"Make your house a home,"
and so when she'd come over,
she'd get really mad if we
didn't have curtains, or...
And I'm like,
"I can't afford curtains."
So I would go
to the fabric place
and buy the discount fabric
and then make curtains.
-That's great. Could you tell it
was discount fabric?
-Yeah.
-Like, did the sun come
right through it?
-Yeah.
-Actually, it caught on fire
a couple of times.
-Yeah, right. [ Laughs ]
-Highly flammable material.
-[ Laughs ] Right.
-[ Laughs ]
-And then, over the years,
have you done other --
have you sewn other --
-Oh, yeah, no. Then I evolved to
Halloween costumes
for my nieces and nephews
and then to dresses.
I would, like, make dresses
for my girlfriends.
And now -- now I'm just
a seamstress to my friends.
Like, they bring pants
over and like,
"can you hem these?"
-Really?
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-I would think they would assume
you have more important things
to do than hem their pants.
-No, apparently not.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-I'd like to sew --
I'd like to learn how to sew
a Halloween costume.
-Oh! Oh, they're hard.
-I think I would feel -- yeah.
They're actually hard.
-Don't start with them?
Start with flammable curtains?
Yeah.
-Yeah.
Start with straight lines, yeah.
-Yeah, exactly.
-One time, my nephew --
I always let my nieces
and nephews pick
what they want to be, and then
I go find the pattern.
And so one's, like, a vampire.
I'm like, good, great, easy.
You know? Princess, got it,
That's a dress.
-Yeah.
-And then one year
my nephew goes, "spider!"
and I was like, ooh.
-Yeah.
-Ooh.
it's a lot of legs and --
-Exactly.
-Ah, that's a lot of work.
How about -- How about --
Why don't we use vampire again?
-[ Laughs ]
You're going to be half
a spider, with four legs.
-[ Laughs ]
-And two of them are
going to be your arms. Um...
-[ Laughs ]
-So, this is your fashion line,
and this is a photo shoot.
-Yeah.
-These are the ads
for your fashion line,
and these are --
-Those are my dogs!
-Actual dogs that you used.
-Yeah.
-And I will say --
Jinxy and Popeye,
which is "Popeye" in Spanish.
-And they look very dignified,
and they look like they are
professional dog models.
-No, they are assholes.
-They were?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Was it a bad scene? 'Cause I've
take an few photos
with my dog,
and it's a bad scene.
Yeah, they're not cooperative
at all.
This was the one frame that they
were actually cooperating.
-Yeah.
-If you saw all
the other frames, it's like...
[ Growls ]
They're trying to
get out of my arms.
-So it's more like wiggling
was the problem?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-They can't stay still.
-Now, was there --
Every time there's a dog shoot,
I like to think of the idiots
who are on the other side of
the camera going,
"over here! Oh, oh, oh!
Over here!"
-[ Screeching
and clicking teeth ]
-Can I assume those idiots were
in full effect here?
-Yeah, yeah,
the same idiots backstage.
-Oh, good.
They were lovely. I met them.
[ Laughter ]
They were so nice.
You would never have guessed
what idiots they were.
-My hair and makeup. No...